well this has been a examination of the
retail market for petrol and Diesel run
by the competition and markets Authority
which is concerned that competition was
weakening in that market as a
consequence drivers consumers uh
businesses were paying more for fuel and
they have found their suspicions were
right particularly a weakening
competition in the supermarket sector
huge volumes of fuel sold through
supermarkets particularly the big four
supermarkets many of them for several
years linking it in attempts to offering
offering deals linking to attempts to
try and encourage people to drive to
their big out of town supermarkets and
get uh get discounts for shopping as
well as mine well they've found that a
weakening of competition between the
supermarkets has seen prices effectively
go up we should remember the vast
majority of the amount of a liter of
fuel is still Taxation and crude oil
price and crude oil particularly is
fluctuating because of the war in
Ukraine but the retail margin that's the
bit that's added between in the refinery
and the petrol pump when we fill up our
vehicles that has grown the cost of
about six pence per liter about 900
million pounds in total extra spent by
consumers last year as a consequence the
cause they say is that prices have gone
up like a rocket as the Zone goes and
down like a feather particularly the
role of Asda and Morrisons to a slightly
less degree those two supermarkets as
they're in particular were that offered
the cheapest prices for many years but
for the last couple of years they have
not reduced prices as quickly as they
might have done after those Rises
Morrisons likewise they've not cut
prices as much Tesco and Sainsbury's the
other big supermarkets they haven't had
their own independent pricing policies
they've just pegged their prices to the
cheaper Rivals Asda and Morrisons
because they have not been reducing more
all Supermarket customers have been
paying more
CMA says one one remedy here is to get
real-time fuel information into the
hands of consumers so Force suppliers
Force retailers to provide real-time
information that can be shared with
consumers and drivers you could imagine
a world in which it's available via your
Sat Nav in your car that you might be
relaying via your phone and that will
help drive down prices the government
this morning have backed that 100 the
chance around at the energy Minister
Grant shots have both said the law will
be changed so that retailers will have
to provide price information in real
time last week interestingly Supermarket
bosses or senior Figures were in front
of MPS on the business select committee
and Morrison certainly said they would
support that scheme plenty of others
have so there's going to be a change in
the way we access fuel information that
should introduce some more competition
won't change the fact that taxes and oil
still ultimately set the price of fuel